president Trump issued two pardons
yesterday one to Patrick Nolan a former
Republican state legislative leader and
the other to my next guest former media
Baron historian author Conrad Black in
2007 black was convicted after
prosecutors accused him of quote several
acts of mail fraud and obstruction
that's worth noting that several of
these convictions were struck down by
the US Supreme Court but black still
served 42 months in prison got a
sentence cut short but not short enough
and he was forced to leave the United
States upon his release now despite all
this as well as pleas for his clemency
from luminaries of every political
persuasion this was the reaction today
President Trump is handing out pardon
it's like a very large bunny who loves
rotten eggs usually you have to exhibit
some kind of remorse if you're gonna get
a presidential pardon and Conrad Black
has not exhibited that so if you find
yourself in a bit of a legal pickle and
you're now wondering how to get out of
prison you might want to think about
writing a glowing book about President
Trump here exclusively in its first
American interview since his pardon is
Lord Conrad black honor everybody knows
you and I have known each other for a
long time and I've spoken about your
absurd case for many many years and
written about it but your reaction to
those who say that this was just your
flattery that won you a pardon
Loretha thank you for having me on my
reaction is I have absolutely no reason
to believe that the president is even
aware that I wrote that book he
certainly has never mentioned it and and
in any case anyone who has read it can
see that it is not uncritical it's no
whitewash a point said some of the less
salubrious aspects of his career and I'm
not uncritical of him in general I am a
supporter for policy reasons and he was
at pains to say when he phoned last week
that his motivation and he authorized me
to say this urgently to say this was not
that we've known each other a long time
that I've been generally supportive of
him it is that after careful examination
by the White House Counsel and his legal
staff they confirmed what Alan
Dershowitz and other lawyers
said on my behalf and to the president's
own words where it was an unjust verdict
and I never should have been charged and
it was a bad rap those were his motives
and he gave he handed favor said to his
friends and you know there would be
you'd have five ambassadors in every
embassy and people should note that the
prosecutor who had you in his sights was
Patrick Fitzgerald US attorney in
Chicago
he's now representing Jim Comey and the
the echoes of prosecutorial abuse and
the use of government state authority to
target people any thoughts
yes we found the prosecutors including
the FBI contribution offering absolute
untruths almost every day there was
never any sanction for it I have to say
Laura I know you're a well-qualified
lawyer I'm a lawyer I'm and I haven't
practiced for fifty years but I am in
theory a lawyer and any serious
jurisdiction except the United States
would disbar most of these prosecutors
it's absolutely outrageous what they do
and as everybody knows basically what
they do is they target somebody they
round up everybody near them in whatever
activity is objected to say you'd better
jug your memory or there's an
obstruction of justice going on here and
a conspiracy to subvert justice and
you'll be charged but if you can jog
your memory successfully and help us
then you have an immunity from perjury
and carry on that's how you get a 98
percent conviction rate and North Korean
rate of conviction it's a wonderful
country but there's a real problem in
the justice system Conrad Black I'm
really happy that you got that pardon
and can't wait to see you in the United
States so coming up come on the show in
person when you're in the United States
I always be honored to do it learn think
that all right you take care